qu'est ce qu'on mange à paris et qu'est
ce qu'on mange ici ici hommage plus de
fouet puis nous accuse d'être soutenus
comme c'est nous mêmes thèmes du club à
paris si par l'ue paris j'aime bien
quand c'est en nous on les valeurs
marcher tout seul et les salades et
indifférence de nourriture chez que
parisien mange beaucoup plus raffinée
que nous du chevreuil à la je suis pas
trop quoi du boudin blanc à la crème du
enfin beaucoup de snap quoi et on peut
préférer les petits pois
tu aimes la bouillabaisse n'ont jamais
vu la belle elle est bonne mais il ya
trop de poissons rouges de daya dutruch
se mélange il quand je fais un rapide tu
préfèrerais la bouillabaisse son poisson
on peut pas ne pas la faire et maintenir
les poissonnières elle en fait mais pas
beaucoup de gens lui en donne le réclame
des fois aussi en vain des bouillabaisse
de sharp nom de rage cash mais là j'ai
un des plusieurs poissons mais alors là
en boîte quand je les ces bons
bon ça ça me parler mais j'en ai déjà
porté des cétacés bonnes séquences et
quand je sais pas quand gervais quand
c'est fait pas le vrai pêcheur et
maintenant qui peut m'expliquer ce
qu'est le pastis c'est une boisson est
pour les grains des personnes qui les a
pris surman voit trop comme mon bac il
adore ça il envoie plug si on lui sert à
acheter deux parties celle en bois de
verre quelques fois avant de devenir
parent se jouera pas je sais pas c'était
de l'alcool mais quel âge as-tu laurence
piquet et c'est bien de boire du pastis
à huit ans et demi
non parce qu'après tard vendredi on va
on va avoir l'habitude de prendre deux
parties ce qui on risque d'être soulevés
trop quoi sous qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire partir dans les pommes
et
et on dissout en est la moitié crever
plus ça veut dire qu en commun d'idées
des âneries on sait plus où en est on à
tête qui tourne
je devais te saoule non jamais mais
alors j'aime ça quelquefois quand on met
de la manne que ces politiques ouverts
oui j'ai des cornes
[Musique]